preocupadas por la seguridad las
autoridades ucranianas realizaron
simulacros de respuesta a una eventual
catástrofe nuclear tras los repetidos
bombardeos en la central nuclear de
savory a la mayor de europa
por supuesto que estamos preocupados eso
es seguro y vemos que la situación desde
que el ejército ruso empezó a bombardear
el 5 de agosto ha cambiado drásticamente
los bombardeos en la planta han sido
ampliamente condenados por la comunidad
internacional ucrania y rusia que se
culpan mutuamente por los ataques han
dicho que quieren que los inspectores
del organismo internacional de energía
atómica visiten la instalación
y
queremos ver imparcialidad queremos ver
que el organismo internacional de
energía atómica dice algo sobre la
guerra deben decir algo sobre la
seguridad nuclear no pueden cerrar los
ojos y decir que si ven a los militares
en las armas lo que por supuesto influye
influye directamente en la seguridad del
material nuclear en la central
y el jefe del organismo rafael grossi ha
dicho que está dispuesto a dirigir una
misión en enero dar la presencia de
fuerzas rusas en torno a esta central
amenaza al continente y a otros países
si uno solo de los misiles golpee el
contenedor del combustible nuclear
gastado se provocaría un desastre con la
liberación de desechos altamente
radioactivos con consecuencias similares
a los desastres de fukushima y chernóbil